well you talk to you can figure this out
if you go to any journalism school right
and talk to any student there
you know we should get like fleccas or
somebody or campus reform to do one of
these you know sort of man on the street
interviews with with um
with journalism school uh students and
people studying that major if they have
any you know if you go back to campus
learning
and ask the q and ask the question then
again of
why are you going to journalism school
why do you be journalists the answer i
guarantee you 90
because i want to change the world
because i want to change the world
because i want the world to be a better
place i want this i want that for the
world and
i want that the power of journalism to
get me there okay great but
that's not journalism no that's activism
that's that's not it's like that uh you
saw that woman from the ap who got fired
right the pro-palestinian woman oh yeah
so this woman gets hired by the ap
then there's like she she starts
complaining there's a right-wing smear
campaign
not just pro-palestinian by the way i
mean she was like
the pro-hamas in some cases like
anti-israel yeah variance
but but for for me even right i'm i'm
not gonna even play the political
argument
i'm going to tell you why she should
have been fired period so
whether or not you want to get into her
politics or anything like that
there's one simple fact she gets hired
by the associated press
there's a bunch of people complaining
she's she's pro palestine she's
anti-israel
and the they she argues these were past
tweets and the left says their old
tweets it shouldn't matter
i said why does she want to be a
journalist when she is an advocate
for one side of a conflict what was the
point of her trying to get that job
the ap was right to fire her and they
should have fight they should have never
hired her
someone comes to me and says hey i'd
like to report on the southern border
crisis
i'd be like i'm down we could do some
reporting and then i see
in their twitter it's all just vitriol
about trump and you know and and the
kids in cages i'm going to be like i
don't think you're actually going to
report on this
if i want to hire an activist to do
advocacy i will i want to see a report
from someone who's like
dry and says i spoke with the the
president's administration
you know tom homan said x y and z though
the activist organizations say a b and c
now
okay that's reporting instead what's
happening is
activists are trying to get jobs at news
organizations they've succeeded greatly
and now that she got fired because she's
an activist and the ap
said she tweeted after the fact i looked
at her i looked at her current tweets
yeah they're very out she's retweeting
people who are very pro-palestine
like how can anyone expect to get
legitimate news from someone who is
advocating for an outcome in the
conflict
she's going to tell you bad information
but the activists are claiming it's
free speech under attack and it's a
right-wing smear campaign because they
are subversive and trying to inject
activists into media because they know
if you control the narrative
you control people have access to if
they don't know the truth they can't
fathom the truth
if the only thing they hear is your
propaganda they will side with you
they've been doing it for a long time
and it's working this is one of the
times they failed
and they only failed i don't even think
they failed because of ben shapiro
they're like it's been shapiro's fault
you know he was smearing this journalist
like oh well i mean the ap said
it was unanimous they looked at her
tweets and said nah you
you can't work here you can't do that
and the real question is of course you
know
why did that not come up in the review
process in the hiring
right so maybe you can hire that person
and not say hey what did they put on
social media did
we're gonna talk about a specific issue
we want you to report on this
what's your past work on that you know
let's let's see let's let's see you're
real you know if i'm if i'm getting
someone in you know
um you know in terms of videos like hey
let me let me see your reel let me see
your sizzle reel right what
what do you got what do you got for me
oh okay so you're you're completely in
the tank for this one side
think about how in my opinion you'd have
to be really
dumb to even consider doing this let's
say
this person who is you know anti-israel
pro-palestine says i want to be a
journalist and i'm going to go and i'm
going to report from this place it's
like what do you think is going to
happen
if some of these like very strong
results of the other side
get wind of your reporting you've got ap
says we'd like you to go and interview
this zionist extremist really out there
street you know group of people they're
going through the streets and they're
they're angry and crazy
and then this journalist is going to
show up and they're going to be like we
looked at you
we looked at your twitter history you
you think that you're going to engage in
act
in in propagandizing for one side of a
conflict and be able to go and interview
the other side
they're gonna be like you're you're
clearly not my friend
first of all you can't get the interview
so even if it was just
activism but let alone the fact that you
might actually be perceived as a
belligerent
it's like actually coming to do them
harm now that's mostly true of
anti-fun what we've seen in new york and
stuff it's typically not the israeli
groups the the pro-israel groups that
are going around attacking people so
i'll make sure that's clear but you
can't expect to do an interview at all
if if a journalist shows up and tries to
interview someone on the right
you know and shameless book plug but
like i just did the antifa book it just
came out into the book.com but we get
into this where
julio rojas from town hall where he
would go
and he's at these events and just
trying to be there as media and he's
like i want to just
interview people who are part of antifa
who are trying to you know i did this
myself in 2017 andy knows going out
there
um you know i hope everything's okay
with andy right now of course know that
you know he's got a situation
but was that him uh i don't know
for sure if that was him and but
he hasn't tweeted since we've reportedly
a situation put it that way just
regardless hope you're safe um you know
i pray for the guy
and but you know that these these antifa
groups
they will get if they see you filming
regardless of who you are
unless they know right there's something
came up when i was in chaz
and if they don't recognize you and they
know you by
sight or they you know they've kind of
seen you around the scene before they
you know have some kind of an idea of
you or or most likely
they've been following you on social
media and so you're sort of an approved
documenter
they will get in your face they will put
up umbrellas they will attack you they
will assault you they will milkshake you
they will you know
try to push you down concrete steps like
they did to me at the lincoln statue
last year so if you are identified as
someone who is
you know seen as a conservative or even
someone who's just not on
our team right you are pushed out you
are not allowed
to do anything with this and this is
actually they handed so with julio in
his situation this in dc
i believe they actually handed him a
list of if you're going to cover us you
have to follow all of these rules
you can't you can't you can't film
something where uh someone's committing
a crime
you can't film anyone's faces if their
mask comes off uh you can't film if
anyone has their phone out any of these
different things that could possibly
identify them right
and they are setting these and so the
question then becomes if you
are someone who considers yourself a
journalist and you're going in and
embedding or at least getting close to
these events
are you following those rules and if
you're doing so then are you taking
their side
of course you're working for them you're
you're licking their feet
let me i'll tell you a story i went to
boston and there was a right-wing pro
right-wing thing i think it was like
2018.
and there was a left-wing counter
anti-foot group shows up
the first thing i have to point out what
were the
right-wing individuals holding they were
all holding some kind of object
they were holding shields what were the
antifa people holding
what do you think two by fours clubs
crowbars bats two by fours
and so i'm like clearly someone's come
here to fight and beat people and
clearly someone's here
uh seeking to defend themselves but
something interesting happened
there was a a an individual who
looked like a lefty but was a journalist
taking pictures of both sides
but was wearing like some like you know
lgbt pride stuff
right and they went over to uh take
photos
of the right wing group some guy a
couple guys on the right started
screaming
you know fu antifa and the three
percenters who were there
immediately ran up and stopped the right
wing guys and told them to shut up back
off
and let them take photos really yeah
there was there were several periods
where the right were trying to get rowdy
and the three percent has immediately
told him to back off and we're screaming
at him
so the three percent of guys that were
there were just wearing like
they didn't have any weapons they were
wearing like some kind of light tactical
gear but didn't really have much with
them
and they were telling people on the
right to chill out back up
get away so when someone from the left
would come over they would immediately
turn around and tell the right to chill
out
well i think that was the right move
because i'd imagine these guys on the
right would pummel one of these antifa
guys pretty bad
they're by themselves walking over you
know what i mean so what do i see when i
when when i walk over to the antifa side
and i i'm dressed like a right wing guy
i get i get a guy swinging at me
he hits my phone a couple times trying
to get in my face he tells me to hit him
and that that's the difference between
what happens when you go and try and
report on these things
the people on the right i can walk i can
walk into you know
go back to occupy wall street era i show
up at cpac
there's like 2012 cpac and i'm walking
around and
literally nothing no problems nothing
happens
people are like how's it going have a
nice day that's it you show up to one of
these occupy protests
even when i was down there and half the
people liked me i still had antifa
attacking me
i was physically attacked three times in
new york during occupy wall street
proper
physically attacked by these people and
they supposedly liked me
so why would why would a journalist want
to be involved in that
you have to basically just tell them you
have to say whatever they want you to
say
so you're not really doing reporting
well so we go i get into this a little
bit in my chaz chapter as well because
when we when we talked about the
journalistic
failures that were going on and actually
chief carmen best who was this the
police chief that resigned
in seattle in the wake of all this um
and has said that it was like a
disinformation campaign because
here's what would happen is the dynamic
was the media would go there most of the
mainstream media would go during that
including fox news would go there during
the day
right they would set up they would have
their huge cameras their huge lights
they would do a hit and you know during
that time you get like the day trippers
you get tourists
you get people just there with their
kids walking around and it is sort of
generally a sociable atmosphere you know
people you know drugs are kind of you
know freely going
around there's no police remember that
was the whole thing there was no police
for 12 blocks
so then at night all of those reporters
would leave and they would go back to
their hotels or go to the bar and drink
craft beer whatever they'd leave
that's when all of the violence was
going on that's when the black blocks
would really start coming out in force
that's when you actually saw criminal
gang
elements that had nothing to do with the
social justice or antifa aspects of this
but would come in because hey there's no
cops here so we can go commit crimes
and we can go do deals where we don't
have to worry about being caught
that's also where you then got those
shootings there were five
shootings on four separate occasions all
throughout chats happened right after i
left and i said this is going
to be a bubbling cauldron of violence
i said that you know as we're walking
out i pulled my mask off and we kind of
did like a live stream saying
you know this is going to get bad jenny
durkin who
was the mayor now is not running again
by the way in seattle because i think we
know what happened there
um it's you had people dying you had
people being shot you had people
being killed because and reportedly this
the investigation is still open but a
lot of those early reports were that it
was the chad security the john brown gun
club
that had actually been involved in some
of these shootings because
they were had this paranoid belief that
and
they were very specific about this that
the kkk was about to show up and raid
chess not the boogaloo boys
not proud boys not i mean they knew who
proud boys were but they
they were all certain that the kkk of
seattle which apparently
they think is a thing i've i've never
heard or seen anything we got we got
we got to stop using we got to stop
using their words
it wasn't it wasn't chad security it was
terroristic insurgents
precisely so the what we often see with
these conflicts is that
the left will say it's uh george floyd
square
and then what happens is the media shows
up and they film the peaceful
inhabitants at george floyd square
except for you know a couple weeks ago
when 30 gunshots ring out in the report
it was drive-by shooting square
well exactly and so we keep referring to
these things the way they demand they be
referred to well this is why with the
whole chaz chop thing
right so they realized very early on
that chaz was really really bad branding
in their part right
capitol hill autonomous zone and then
the minute that media narrative got out
and people said wait what do you mean
you've declared yourselves autonomous
you're autonomous from the united states
your own country
within a couple of days they get up no
no we're just kidding we're actually the
chop we're just
it's just an occupied protest we're
trying to bring back some of that get
good will
from you know zakati park and the
original occupy no no no but what did
what did conservatives do
a lot of conservatives adopted chop i
never did i wouldn't even call this all
the way through i won't even call it
that
what did you call it a no-go zone it was
a no-go that's it
that's what this was a far left
extremist no go zone
you look at the definition of a no-go
zone look at the standard colloquial
understanding it means a place where the
police are reticent to go
or the the medical professionals ems
police they don't want to go there it's
too dangerous individuals only enter
with great personal risk
that's exactly what these places are so
we actually tracked one of the guys who
was a member of this genre or at least
suited up to join the john brown gun
club in chas
and daniel allen baker this is a guy who
was later arrested
early 2021 down in tallahassee florida
why
because he was planning a left-wing
armed action at the at the florida court
excuse me florida capital right
daniel allen baker he goes out there
travels from florida
to chaz to create to be this sort of
militia security group
where did he have his training he's one
of these antifa guys that actually went
to syria
to join the battlefield forces of the
ypg
this is the kurdish group that's out
there they're tied to the pkk who
are terrorist designated group he's
actually out there on the battlefield
but of course because they were fighting
isis at the time and you know sort of
more infighting for the kurdish areas
you get all these stories in rolling
stone he's actually in one of the vice
documentaries from syria talking about
how great it
is that these these left-wing um just
true believers are out here fighting for
something
fighting for their own land right it was
almost sort of like they're trying to
create this stateless space
up there in northeast syria he comes
back has the training from the
battlefield has the ttps
he goes up there in chats and we've got
these these quotes from him we've got
tweets from him
and he's saying look if we really want
to have an autonomous zone we've got to
take this to the next level need we need
more guns
we need explosives we need all sorts of
things i'm quoting him by the way
and we need to take this to the next
level because eventually the police are
just going to come in here and shut this
down
but god he was really pushing them to go
forward now of course we know that
didn't happen
but that very same guy claims he claims
uh that he was one of the medics
involved in one of these shootings the
question is of course was he there as a
medic or was he there or something else
or one of the people that stripped all
the evidence out of the vehicle when
they pumped it full of hundreds of
rounds killing two teenagers precisely
so they killed they killed one that time
the other one's arrived the other one
survived yeah
and now there's i think a couple
lawsuits these people who are killed
the parents are blaming the city i mean
the city could have come in and took it
all up
but these these these democrat leaders
they're
they favor this stuff right and it is it
does kind of create the moral question
of you know do the people of the city
now do they deserve it no obviously not
and this is why i keep telling people
just get out of city so you just you
just need to be out of cities for a
while because
a lot of the people in the cities you
look at places like i'm i'm from the
philadelphia
originally they just re-elected the d.a
who's like let's let's not prosecute
people let's let people out of jail
uh larry krasner so that he just won the
primary
handle handily won the primary there so
they are voting
for this kind of stuff st louis same
situation right
st louis which is now one of the murder
capitals in terms of homicide rate of
the united st
louis right who would have thought right
that that would have been you know
ferguson i know you're a ferguson
um and so if they're voting for this
again and again right the question is is
is this what they want
let me ask you a question that yeah so
so jack just mentioned there was a guy
in uh this was the the seattle no-go
zone with the terroristic insurgents at
the far left and he was talking about
how they wanted to escalate things
but it never happened this guy who
wanted violence and explosives was he
prosecuted was he locked up did the feds
come and and arrest him they put out his
photo and say please help
us stop this dangerous terrorist uh
yes but not for that not until much much
much
later when he said that he was going to
do something at the tallahassee
capitol in florida in 2021 for all of
his activity
again going to the middle east and
training with a terrorist designated
group
going to chas being involved in all this
stuff not prosecuted thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you